prenez une feuille et un stylo
non je plaisante vous n'êtes pas venu
ici pour faire une dictée mais c'est
bien comme ça que je vais commencer mon
histoire
lorsque j'avais 6 7 ans j'avais vraiment
très envie d'avoir un stylo plume
j'avais vraiment très envie d'avoir un
stylo plume parce que pour moi 6,7 en
avoir un stylo plume c'était être adulte
être prise au sérieux et à 6 7 ans
j'avais vraiment très envie d'être une
adulte conception qui change avec le
temps
j'ai donc passé un marché avec mes
parents si je ne faisais aucune faute
d'orthographe donc que j'obtenais 100 %
à 10 dictée consécutive
mes parents m'ont ferait un stylo plume
mes parents ont accepté et je suis parti
sur maquette du stylo plume première
dictée aucune faute d'orthographe 100%
tout va bien 2e 3e 9e dictée tout va
toujours bien on arrive à la dernière
dictée on arrive à la dernière phrase de
la dernière dictée
comme vous vous en doutez
il me manque un petit est ce un
participe passé m'a raccordé qui me vaut
98 sur 100 et adieu le c'est ok
c'est pour être en est probablement le
meilleur titre que j'aurais pu trouver à
ma présentation ce soir
ses fautes d'orthographe qui changent
notre histoire
alors je vous parle pas de cette faute
d'orthographe que l'on remarque juste
après avoir appuyé sur envoyer un
courriel important à notre patron non
celle ci je peux rien pour vous si
quelqu'un a une solution miracle je suis
preneuse
moi je vous parle de fautes
d'orthographe dans notre génome
notre génome ou adn c est une suite de
lettres une suite de quatre lettres pour
être exact que l'on appelle nucléotides
as they say et g
notre génome
c'est en partie
ce qu'ils racontent notre histoire c'est
en partie ce qui fait que nous sommes
nous c'est ce qui fait que je suis brune
c'est ce qui fait que vous êtes blond
que vous avez les yeux bleus ou que j'ai
les yeux bruns
notre génome en partie raconte notre
histoire
aujourd'hui nous sommes capables de le
lire notre génome
alors au début des années 2000 nous
pouvions lire notre génome pour la
modique somme de 100 millions de dollars
américains
par personne
aujourd'hui on est sur des sommes
beaucoup plus raisonnables pour mille
dollars vous vous ou moi pouvons
séquencé le génome pouvant lire notre
génome
mais pouvons-nous le comprendre
pour ça il faut déjà comprendre comment
notre génome est organisée est ce que
quelqu'un peut me dire ici ce que ça ça
veut dire
je vous rassure moi non plus
il faut déjà comprendre que s'est
organisée d'une certaine façon en 1961
nous avons découvert que s'est organisée
sous forme de triple et cela prend trois
nucléotides pour avoir un co dont
un co dont c'est un peu comme une
syllables et en 1965 nous avons réussi à
découvrir le code génétique en gros nous
avons réussi à trouver
quelques dons correspond à quelle
syllables par exemple nous savons que
nous avons un cordon particulier qui est
un signal ouvrez les guillemets et que
nous avons un coût dont en particulier
qui est un signal fermez les guillemets
donc si on reprend notre morceau de
génomes de tout à l'heure on est
maintenant capable de trouver un signal
ouvrez les guillemets suivi d'une cible
de suite deux syllabes formant un mot et
d'un signal fermez les guillemets
cela donne un mot qui est ce que l'on
appelle une protéine une protéine c'est
un peu l'ouvrière de la cellule en fait
soyons honnêtes celles qui font tourner
cela a pris 15 ans et 3 milliards de
dollars d'investissements pour réussir à
obtenir dans les années 2000 le premier
dictionnaire du génome alors c'est un
format un peu différent du larousse ou
du petit robert
mais c'est un dictionnaire qui contient
absolument tous les maux de notre génome
22 ans après que l'on sache lire et
qu'on a un dictionnaire
est ce que l'on est capable de tout
comprendre si je lis mon génome est ce
que je suis capable de comprendre mon
histoire
vingt-deux ans après savoir lire et
avoir un dictionnaire
sommes nous capables de comprendre
toutes les maladies héréditaires une
maladie héréditaire ou une maladie
génétique
c'est un peu comme une faute
d'orthographe dans votre génome un mot
mal orthographié et qui change votre
histoire une lettre de différence
chapeau
château près similaire mais quand même
différent surtout si vous essayez de le
mettre sur la tête
aujourd'hui alors que cela fait 22 ans
que l'on sait lire et qu'on a un
dictionnaire c'est encore deux maladies
héréditaires sur 5 que nous ne
comprenons pas
deux histoires sur cinq quand on sait
lire et qu'on a un dictionnaire c'est
beaucoup
et s'il nous manquait des mots
s'il nous manquait des mots ou se
cacherait-il
en fait juste son hôte n'est
si cela prend trois nucléotides pour
former une syllabe
ce morceau de génomes derrière moi je
peux le lire de trois façons différentes
en fonction que je commence au 1er
au 2ème ou 3ème
nucléotides
si je commence au deuxième nucléotides
j'obtiens des triplés complètement
différent et je suis capable de trouver
un nouveau signal ouvrez les guillemets
suivie de nouvelles syllables suivi d'un
signal fermez les guillemets qui nous
donne un tout nouveau mot une toute
nouvelle protéine
alors
si on cherche bien
si on pose la question
on est capable de les trouver ces
nouveaux mots on est capable de les
identifier dans nos cellules
et la grande majorité
proviennent de ce domaine
alors qu'est ce que c'est qu'un pseudo
gêne si le génome et l'ensemble de nos
gènes qu'est ce qu'un pseudo gêne
c'est pas de la pseudo science
1 en fait un pseudo gêne
c'est un gène pas vraiment on n'est pas
sûr on sait que ce n'est pas fonctionnel
pour être honnête c'est à peu près ça la
définition d'un pseudo j'aime
en réalité un pseudo gêne c'est une
copie d'un gène fonctionnel prenons par
exemple ici un gène ou un mot vert vers
un pseudo gnc une copie de ce gène qui
va accumuler des mutations ou devrais je
dire des fautes d'orthographe cette
accumulation de fautes d'orthographe
c'est exactement la raison pour laquelle
on pense que c'est une non fonctionnel
ici c'était un centre de recyclage
cette accumulation de fautes
d'orthographe à travers le temps peu
petit à petit forme et un nouveau mot
similaire mais légèrement différent par
exemple vers vem peut devenir vert vrt
ça se ressemble beaucoup mais ça veut
pas dire exactement la même chose
alors là vous m'écoutez
mais
pourquoi est ce qu'on voudrait savoir si
ces pseudos homos sont vraiment des mots
en fait c'est parce que quand je vous
dis qu'on est capable de lire votre
génome on ne lit pas du début à la fin
sans prendre de pause
somme toute qui ici à lui les sept
postes les sept tomes d'harry potter de
a à z sans prendre de pause
si vous l'avez fait félicitations vous
avez tout mon respect la plupart d'entre
nous nous allons le lire chapitre par
chapitre
voire même paragraphe par paragraphe
pour notre génome c'est un peu la même
chose nous le lisons morceau par morceau
est ce que nous voyons ce sont des
fragments de notre génome
si dans mon dictionnaire
le seul mot que j'ai et le move
rvr les fragments qui sont derrière moi
peuvent me laisser penser que j'ai des
fautes d'orthographe un thé
un ace un accent alors que je ne devrais
pas en avoir
mais si nous étions capables
de voir la phrase en entier cela
donnerait peut-être une réalité très
différente
inverse père sévère
vers le vert vert à l'envers l'idée vert
de prévert
c'est une phrase que j'aime beaucoup
nombre d'entre vous la trouveront
complexe moi je la trouve intéressante
c'est peut-être pour ça que je suis
scientifique
mais cette phrase nous permet surtout
de dire que la seule chose que l'on peut
faire avec les fragments que nous avions
précédemment ce sont des erreurs
d'orthographes
penser qu'il ya une faute alors qu'il
n'y en a pas
alors on a des mots on a un dictionnaire
qui contient des mots on a des mots qui
sont pas des mots on a des mots qui
ressemblent à des mots on a des mots qui
sont cachés on a des mots qui sont des
pseudos mots qui devrait des mots mais
qui sont pas des mots si vous avez des
maux de tête je vous en voudrez pas
comment peut-on vraiment savoir ce qui
est un mot dans notre génome
en fait on n'est pas allé chercher bien
loin on a simplement posé la question à
google bon pas tout à fait en fait on a
utilisé exactement le même algorithme
que celui que google utilise pour la
reconnaissance d'image
ces algorithmes tiré du domaine de
l'intelligence artificielle permettent
de reconnaître certaines choses sur des
photos par exemple
pour l'expérience avec vous j'ai désigné
mon chat volontaire
si je fourni à notre algorithme
suffisamment de photos de mon chat
notre algorithme est capable d'apprendre
que ceci est un chat
et après notre algorithme est ce aussi
capable de nous dire que ceci est aussi
un chat c'est moins évident mais si si
véridique j'ai fait l'expérience
pour les mots c'est exactement la même
chose on donne un autre algorithme des
mots
que l'on sait sont fonctionnels et on
lui demande où sont ceux qu'on aurait pu
rater
alors pourquoi est-ce que ça occupe mes
journées et surtout celle de mes
étudiants
parce qu'au coeur de notre démarche
il y a le patient le patient qui vient
avec une maladie héréditaire et qui
cherchent des réponses
ce patient lorsqu'il est prise en charge
lorsque l'on fait des tests génétiques
son génome et comparer un génome de
référence à notre dictionnaire
si notre dictionnaire n'est pas
exhaustif est exact
ce sont des fautes d'orthographe que
nous pouvons manquer et ce sont aussi
des erreurs d'orthographe que nous vous
que nous pouvons faire
alors avoir un dictionnaire complet et
exhaustif c'est absolument nécessaire
et pour boucler la boucle finalement
gelée umons et aux plumes véridique 1
c'est celui de quand j'avais 6 7 ans
ils l'ont eu parce que certains diront
que je suis têtu moi je préfère le mot
résiliente
mais aussi parce que mes parents m'ont
donné une deuxième chance et à sept ans
j'étais bien loin de me douter que moi
est ce si ce stylo plume à lyon en fait
passer notre carrière à chasser les
fautes d'orthographe alors certes sous
une fois en main peu différente mais
tout de même et j'ai pourtant un
parcours que nombreux jugeront jonché
d'erreurs
je suis d'abord vétérinaire puis j'ai
fait une thèse en pharmacologie avant de
continuer en biochimie pour finalement
utilisé l'intelligence artificielle pour
mieux comprendre notre génome ses
erreurs de parcours c'est ce qui fait
que je suis dans une position unique
pour répondre à ces questions
soyons honnêtes des fautes d'orthographe
dans notre génome on en a tous
c'est ce qui fait que nous sommes nous
c'est ce qui fait que nous sommes
uniques
moi je mon travail c'est simplement de
m'assurer que ça ne soit pas une faute
d'orthographe qui écrivent le mot fin à
votre histoire
[Applaudissements]